55 years ago richard branson was given
an ultimatum
he had been crippled with dyslexia his
whole life to where he could barely read
by the age of eight
and was completely lost when it came to
numbers so school was torture
school was painful you know i'd look at
look at a blackboard and
wouldn't be able to understand anything
that was going on and by high school he
had started his first real business
a magazine for students seeing him
struggle his high school headmaster
called men one day and said you can
either leave school and run the magazine
or you can stay in school and leave the
magazine
so i said thank you for that choice i'm
off to
run the magazine so at age 16 richard
branson became a high school dropout
with this headmaster saying that
branson you're either going to become a
millionaire or go to jail
55 years later this happened
and right now our crew are on their way
to space let's check in
on them via our onboard camera footage
three two one
release release release clean release
[Applause]
space is virgin territory
[Music]
welcome to space
to all you kids down there i was once a
child with a dream
looking up to the stars now i'm an adult
in a spaceship
with lots of wonderful adults looking
down to our beautiful beautiful earth
to the next generation of dreamers if we
can do
this just imagine what you can do
[Music]
[Applause]
main gear touchdown and we're going to
hold it just like this for a minute
before bringing the nose down
can see they're already celebrating
inside there and the nose is coming down
now
nose gear touchdown
richard branson becomes the first
billionaire to fly into space finally
ushering in the new era of space tourism
but what makes a man go from a dyslexic
high school dropout to one of the most
iconic rockstar billionaires out there
who's also an astronaut
let's find out
[Music]
recently i finally got to watch the full
replay of richard branson's flight into
space and i was just in
awe and with blue origin joining the mix
it really does look like space tourism
is going to be a thriving business very
soon
and if you want to get in on this wave
if you want to invest in it the easiest
way is with today's video sponsor weeble
and for a limited time you can get a
free stock value between three dollars
and three hundred dollars just from
opening up an account
you open up an account and they
literally just give you a free stock and
you get another free stock value between
eight dollars and two thousand dollars
just by depositing at least five dollars
into your account when you sign up with
the link below
weeble is a great commission free stock
trading app that i use
because it's got just the right amount
of features without being too basic or
too intimidating
you can buy stocks crypto even dogecoin
etfs options and even fractional shares
meaning that
if you want to invest in amazon but
can't afford the three and a half
thousand dollar price tag for just one
share you can buy just half of a share
or a quarter of a share or really
however little you want
they've got intuitive charts and a ton
of other cool tools built in all in one
place they've got a great desktop app
and they even have 24 7 customer support
reps so pause the video and claim your
two free stocks with the link in the
video description below it's basically
free money so you might as well do it
richard branson was born in london in
1950 branson came from a loving happy
family
and his mom played a key role in his
spirit for adventure she took flying
lessons dressed as a boy
enlisted in world war ii she became one
of the first heir stewardesses in the
world
and she took that spirit for adventure
and pushed branson to be independent
told them to reach for the stars
never imagining where this may take him
when i was a child you threw me out of
the car
miles from my house and urged me to find
my own way home
so just like his mom pushing the edge
became part of his dna
even as a kid branson had an
entrepreneurial spirit him and his
friends first tried breeding and selling
birds to make more money but then a cat
ate them then they tried selling
christmas trees but then rabbits got to
it
although their plans failed it taught
him an important lesson about risk
we just learned bit by bit that you can
take risks but also
you need to protect yourself a little
bit from the things that can happen
and although he had a natural talent for
business branson wasn't good in school
at all because of his dyslexia
but instead of letting that discourage
him he used it as a reason to focus on
the one thing he was good at
business if you look at the history of
dyslexics
they they often exceed quite
exceptionally
because they concentrate on the areas
that they that they're good at
it's certainly taught
fast forward to the 60s and the vietnam
war was in full swing and the youth
wanted a voice
so branson decided that he would be the
one to give it to them so branson
started his first real enterprise at 15
by launching a national student
newspaper aimed at campaigning against
the vietnam war
and it was the 60s people the young
people wanted a voice when i was about
14 the vietnamese wars started
we decided to start a magazine to
campaign against it a magazine to give a
voice to young people
it was an original idea because there
was no national magazine for students
we were having to sell advertising we
were having to attract big contributors
and again that took a lot of cuts i
started off
not thinking of myself as a business
person but thinking of myself as
wanting to make a difference in the
world so i started a magazine to
campaign against
the vietnamese war the biafran war him
and his friends had no idea how to run a
magazine so they had to learn how to
sell advertising space and attract
contributors all while in high school
i soon learned the art that if i let
coke know that
pepsi was definitely in that coke would
then jump in and my
education started and at the time
england was a very socialist environment
and didn't really encourage free
enterprise so branson was a very rare
breed to say the least
it's not surprising that soon after the
magazine took off branson's headmaster
gave him that ultimatum
leave school and run the magazine or
stay in school and leave the magazine
and the rest is history this was a
turning point in his life and the
magazine became one of his very first
successes
he said you're 15 you know what you want
to do
so you know give it a go and if it
doesn't succeed we'll try to get you an
education again
and i could have given the biggest
biggest kiss ever
for his understanding and just four
years later in 1969
600 million people around the world were
watching breast held as neil armstrong
said those famous 11 words as he stepped
onto the moon
and one of those 600 million people was
richard branson he was celebrating his
19th birthday and was kind of hung over
from there a sea was planted in his head
that he would one day be an astronaut
like his heroes neil armstrong buzz
aldrin and michael colony
it was the point that he decided that he
wanted to quote live life on the edge
and to the fullest
[Music]
as a way to make money from the magazine
branson got the idea to sell discounted
music records by mail
and he indeed found a way to sell him at
a huge discount tax fraud
like a true entrepreneur see every
record store in the uk had to pay 33
tax on records they sold branson found a
way to trick the authority so he didn't
have to pay that tax
hence the giant discount for customers
he realized the time was right for a
discounted mail-order record service
so he put an advert in the back of
student magazine the problem was what
would they call the business
so sitting in a basement with a bunch of
girls as a 15 16 year old
and then one of the girls said we're all
virgins
why did you call it virgin since richard
was a version of business and sex he
thought why not
the name was fresh both and very risque
for the times exactly what branson
wanted to project
and the business took off but just five
months after opening the tax man came
knocking and threw him in jail
it looks like the headmaster's
prediction came true wrestling was in
jail and definitely not a millionaire
but obviously his story didn't end there
after his arrest his parents had to
mortgage their home to bail him out and
he learned his biggest lesson yet
do not go directly against authority
although the way he was able to undercut
competitors in this case was illegal
this habit this muscle of undercutting
the competition would continue to serve
him well in his future businesses
a postal strike in 1971 nearly brought
the business to a standstill which led
branson to opening up a record store
also called virgin records and then that
almost came to a
to a very sad end because there was a
mail order strike so we had to find a
way to
keep going
while running the record store branson
came across a guitar demo made by a 15
year old
it was all instrumental and had no
vocals or real structure at all
but branson saw something in that young
artist and he tried pitching the demo to
eight record labels who all very
surprisingly said no
instead of letting that discourage him
he thought squirt let's do it and
created a record label just like that to
record it themselves
tubular bells by mike olfio ended up
being featured in the movie the exorcist
and became one of the albums of the
decade
skyrocketing virgin records into a
legitimate record label taking on the
establishment
the album's success made richard into a
millionaire before his 23rd birthday
fulfilling the other half of this
headmaster's prophecy and virgin records
would grow into one of the most
successful indie labels around
signing janet jackson the sex pistols
and the rolling stones
we were proud of the fact that no
musician ever ever left the record label
and that's why virgin grew into the most
successful independent record label in
the world
this success catapulted branson into the
young rockstar of the business world
and this would start his reputation for
going into giant bloated industries and
completely disrupting them the virgin
way
16 million to be precise overnight
the record put virgin on the map and
made richard branson
not yet 23 a millionaire branson
poured his profits into new artists and
ventures
i'm willing to double down maybe more
than i
recommend to other people
24 year old richard branson was living
the rockstar millionaire life
he owned an island in the british virgin
islands which he bought for a steal of
just 180 000
and virgin records just kept growing
with more money than he knew what to do
with branson turned to expanding the
virgin brandon image through crazy
stunts and adventures to show that
virgin was the cool hip company in town
compared to all the boring faceless
corporations
[Applause]
making richard branson really one of the
first lifestyle influencers way before
youtube
and instagram influencers became a thing
some of these sort of adventurous
things have helped give virgin that sort
of
exciting image we needed to get profile
and one of the
great ways to get profile is to do
things that
are attention getting always looking at
ways to get
the virgin name in front of people but
branson wanted to do more
and out of the blue an insurance lawyer
called them and asked branson to back
him on starting a transatlantic airline
it just so happened that branson also
hated flying on the current airlines
so as he always said screw it let's do
it
simon draper you know and my other poor
partners would be
tearing their hair out because you know
suddenly
you know i was saying you know i hate
traveling on other people's airlines and
we can do it better
when branson launched virgin atlantic
one simply didn't just start an airline
see back then the airline industry was
very regulated in the us a few
monopolies controlled the market
in europe a few state-owned airlines
controlled the market and all of them
worked to crush
any new competition virgin atlantic was
launched with a single used airplane
leased from boeing and none of branson's
partners or the world thought it would
work
my shares which i owned at that time 15
of the whole virgin group were becoming
pretty valuable
people thought we were absolutely off
our heads
all he's got is a record company people
around the record company
were distraught i was going to put this
very successful record company at risk
and go into the airline business
you full of feel the whole thing could
collapse like a pack of cards
i hated flying on other people's
airlines i mean you know particularly
british airways
braz's biggest problem was promotion but
luckily that was where he shined
and the virgin atlantic launch party had
it all topless models
alcohol and non-stop fun and to promote
an airline with a single plane flying
only one route
with a limited advertising budget
branson put his stunt adventures into
overdrive
whether it was trying to cross the
atlantic in a hot air balloon which
almost got him killed multiple times or
driving a tank down 5th avenue in new
york
his viral marketing quickly made virgin
atlantic into a household name
so i hit that water i far opened the
life vest i popped back out but virgin
atlantic's biggest competitor british
airways
wasn't happy with this newcomer on the
block so they launched what the media
would call the dirty tricks campaign
i think it was down to british
establishment seeing this young
upstart british airways were spread
rumors that virgin atlantic was about to
go under they would spy on them hacked
their computers called virgin's
customers saying that their flight was
cancelled stuff like that
every day you take off if you've got
empty seats you've lost money
so if somebody can persuade passengers
not to boot with a certain airline
because they think it's going to go bust
it will go bust but branson wasn't about
to go down without the fights
so he decided to sue british airways for
libel but he needed a lot of money
behind them to fund it so that's when he
made one of the hardest decisions of his
life
sell virgin records his baby the company
that started it all for him
to fund the lawsuit people thought he
was insane for risking such a successful
record company for a risky airline for
branson selling the label was like
selling his child
to save the airline branson had to make
the toughest call of his life
he decided to sell his beloved record
company
she cried you cried and cried it was a
bit like selling a child
branson sells for a billion dollars and
i realized life wasn't
wasn't that bad but it all worked out
for the better after selling virgin
records for a billion dollars he had
enough backing to sue british airways
for libel they settled british airways
had to make a public apology
and what branson would refer to as one
of the greatest days in his business
career
and later on the record industry tanked
anyways when the battle was over richard
turned all his focus into growing the
virgin brand even more
and in 1988 while filming a children's
show for the bbc
a kid asked branson if he ever thought
of going to space
um have you ever thought about going
into space richard
i'd love to go into spaces i think
pretty well everybody watching this show
would
love to go to space i mean when you see
those
magnificent pictures of in space and the
incredible views
um i think there could be nothing nicer
so
if you're building a spacecraft i'd love
to come with you on it he registered the
name virgin galactic the very next day
branding is what virgin is all about
branson set out to embody that brand and
he did everything he could to promote it
he believed that they could do better
than all the bloated industries out
there and proceeded to virginize more
than 300 products and services
i wasn't thinking right let's just take
this brand into lots of different areas
i just
felt you know we can do better in health
clubs we can do better
in mobile phone business some worked
some went under but he didn't stop
expanding
some ventures like virgin brides and
virgin cola
fizzled quickly the uk's train network
was another horrible industry branson
wanted to turn around
he reached out to the head of british
rail who then proceeded to swear that he
would never let branson get a hold of
one of their trains
i'm not going to let that branson get
hold of our trains we then contacted the
government and
said we're willing to stick our necks
out and create a great train
service if if you privatize part of the
train network so he reached out to the
government to let him privatize some of
the trains
and virgin trains became a thing this
project took years to materialize and
even longer for the trains to run on
time
in 1999 branson turned his attention to
the expensive cell phone carrier
industry
partnered with a company that provided
the network and branson brought the
virgin name and came up with the idea of
letting users pay as they go
he struck gold and took the brand public
through an ipo five years later at 1.5
billion dollars
that same year he became business
royalty after being knighted by the
queen for his contributions to commerce
richard branson was now served richard
branson
[Music]
today the virgin brand has more than 400
products and services under its umbrella
branson still owns and lives on necro
island in the caribbean he wakes up
every day at sunrise
goes kite surfing to start off his day
and often spends time outdoors between
appointments
sometimes even taking business calls
from the bathtub and the island is also
a resort that you can pay over a hundred
thousand dollars a night to stay at
it's hosted a ton of world leaders like
nelson mandela jimmy carter
obama and branson seems to genuinely
love living there
it also gives him the benefit of living
in a tax haven even though his record
label days are far behind him he still
lives like a rock star
he owns lodges and houses all over the
world collectable cars
and still hates wearing suits and ties
branson has never had a fear of failure
and that may be the one thing that led
him to what is arguably his greatest
achievement yet
travels beyond our world richard branson
is the guy behind
everything virgin the old record stores
the airline and now
space travel at least as close as you
can get for a price
200 grand in 2004 branson took one of
his biggest risks yet
space by now he was used to people
telling him that his ideas were insane
but virgin has already done practically
every dangerous stunt possible on earth
so he saw not taking verge into space
was a bigger risk than actually going
his plan to make a space launch system
to send salads and science experiments
into space
while funny entirely with space tourism
instead of with government money
they would commercialize space travel
and take regular rich people into space
beginning with his mom this dream took
him across the world partnering with
companies as far flung as abu dhabi and
is seen as if virgin galactic was only a
few months away from reaching their
goals
when on october 31st 2014 virgin
galactic spaceship 2 crashed into the
mojave desert
killing one of the two pilots a deadly
setback today for virgin galactic and
the entire space tourism industry
a virgin galactic spaceship crashed
during a test flight in california
the news devastated branson who felt
hesitant to continue
but after discovering the crash wasn't
caused by a technical error the team
pressed on
if it wasn't for that crash space
tourism probably would have arrived much
sooner
it's been seven years since the incident
and just this month the virgin galactic
vision became a reality
branson entered space for a full 72
seconds on july 11 2021
claiming space as virgin territory
to all you kids down there i was once a
child with a dream
looking up to the stars now
i'm an adult in a spaceship with lots of
other wonderful adults looking down
to our beautiful beautiful earth to the
next generation of dreamers
if we can do this just imagine
what you can do
[Music]
if there's one thing that has stayed
true throughout branson's entire life is
always working hard while playing hard
would i be wrong and saying that one of
your mantras as well it is to have
fun along the way you're kind of pretty
well known for the pranks that you pull
and the i think i look i think life is
life is short life should be fun and it
should be fun not you know
it should be if the the chairman of the
company's having fun you know if you go
to a party and
you know if i let my hair down and i'm
the first to be thrown in the swimming
pool and
uh and i'm not just sitting standing in
the corner of the room sipping
sherry or something then everybody will
have a laugh and everybody have it fun
you know if your gemini company be the
first to dance on the table you know
just
get everybody else up dancing on the
table and make sure the parties
you know the party's a laugh so play
hard work hard and then
you know follow certain principles in
life you know be you know
love people make make sure you make a
positive difference in this world
while you're on it and while richard
branson may be a billionaire it's
important to realize that that was never
his primary focus
when asked about his philosophy on money
this is what he had to say
does money make you happy or not when i
started off
not thinking of myself as a business
person but thinking of myself as
wanting to make a difference in the
world so i started a magazine to
campaign against
the vietnamese war the biafran war in
africa
and money was just a means to try to
get enough money in to pay for the
magazine to make sure it could come out
every week
and ever since then i've created things
which where i think it can make a
difference in the world
hopefully at the end of the year more
money comes in
than goes out to pay the bills money is
useful
to you know if you if your children are
ill if you want to get a decent
education
you know if you want to have a holiday
yeah you know there are some basic
necessities with money
but once you've actually you know you
had your breakfast lunch dinner
and done those things you know money's
not that important now
if you have money therefore you just
must make the best of it and make good
use of it
and and you know use it to transform the
world
and i think that that is a very
commendable way to look at things
you do only live once and if you're
capable of doing
some extraordinary things you know you
should get out and try to do them
well the brave may not live forever but
the cautious
do not live at all
[Music]
i've never followed richard branson too
much so when i was researching this
video i was genuinely shocked he is a
pure rock star which i think is so cool
i left out a ton of stuff about his life
because if i've included everything
this video would be like hours long and
it still wouldn't be enough and you can
get two free stocks with today's video
sponsor weeble when you open up an
account you're gonna get one free stock
value between three dollars and three
hundred dollars and you can get another
free stock value between eight dollars
and two thousand dollars just by
depositing at least five dollars into
your
account it's basically free money do
with the link below and support the
channel
would you buy a ticket to go up in the
space i 100 will and can't wait to do it
if you guys enjoyed this video i
recommend you guys checking out our
video on bernard or no he is the second
to third richest man in the world
depending on how
the markets are and he also built an
epic brand empire but in the world of
fashion and luxury
you can check that out on the channel
and of course if you're new here we make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most thought
provoking and provocative stuff in the
world of business
all you have to do is click the
subscribe button below you can follow me
on instagram
jaketrend.io for more behind the scenes
day in the life kind of stuff and as
always thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
do
you